los bañistas en una playa en el sur de
italia miran como una columna de humo
sale de un bote que transporta unos 20
migrantes las autoridades dijeron que al
menos tres de los que estaban a bordo
murieron después de que el barco se
incendió es el último drama en la
creciente afluencia de inmigrantes a
italia luego de que casi 400 personas
asignadas en un barco de pesca llegaron
a lampedusa el sábado su llegada provocó
protestas en los lugareños y algunos
intentaron evitar que los inmigrantes
desembarcaron
esta noche lampedusa dice basta esta
noche lampedusa dice basta
el gobierno es cómplices
el alcalde de lampedusa tomártelo dijo
que la isla ya no podía hacer frente al
flujo de migrantes y pidió una huelga
general el lunes apenas unas horas antes
otras 49 personas fueron llevadas a la
isla habían sido rescatadas por la
guardia costera italiana en un voto
humanitario de rescate peligrosamente
abarrotado financiado por el artista
urbano bansí
los recién llegados fueron trasladados a
un centro de recepción de emergencia en
la isla que alberga a casi 1200 personas
diez veces su capacidad máxima según
datos del ministerio del interior- unos
18.000 inmigrantes han llegado a las
costas de italia en lo que va de año en
comparación con poco menos de cinco mil
en el mismo periodo de 2010 y nueve